[APPLAUSE]
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Thank you
guys for coming to Google.
It's a pleasure
having you guys here.
ARIJIT SINGH: Well,
it's our pleasure.
ROSHNI SUCHDE: And
our pleasure too.
Yes.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: But yeah, I know
you guys are here on a concert.
Do you guys want
to talk about it?
ROSHNI SUCHDE: Yes.
Thank you.
We have, yes, we have a concert
tour with symphony orchestra
for Arijit Singh live.
We're doing seven cities
starting from New Jersey
this Saturday onwards.
So this coming Saturday,
guys, mark your calendar.
We're doing in New
Jersey, and then we'll
be heading out to Orlando
the following weekend.
That would be Friday.
Then after, we're
heading back to San Jose.
Then we're doing L.A. and we're
going to Houston, Chicago,
and Dallas.
So yes, seven cities.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Wow.
That's crazy.
ARIJIT SINGH: But
I didn't know that.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: I've been to
Arijit's concert before and one
of the greatest
experiences of my life.
I really highly recommend it.
It's really, really good.
ROSHNI SUCHDE: Thank you.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: We also have
a discount for Googlers only.
So you get 15% off.
So, yeah.
Definitely check it out.
We have a GoLink to it, so
definitely check it out.
I will send out a reminder too.
ROSHNI SUCHDE: Thank you.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: So let me ask
the first question to Roshni.
ARIJIT SINGH: OK, yes.
Please.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: So
Roshni, how excited
were you where you first got
a chance to meet Arijit Singh
and to work with
him and to promote
this concert and his songs
and music here in the States,
and especially with a lot of
Indian community here too.
ROSHNI SUCHDE: Like,
honestly speaking,
it's like a dream come
true kind of thing,
because you hear him, right?
You see the fan
following that he has.
His songs basically touch
your soul immediately.
So when you get to
meet him personally
and when you hear him, it's
a whole different experience.
And that too, when you see
that you are working with them,
it's a completely
different experience.
Yes.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Definitely.
Yeah, Arijit is one of the
greatest singers in Bollywood.
So Arijit, how did
you get into music?
How did you know from
childhood that you wanted
to pursue this professionally?
ARIJIT SINGH: Well, this is
all in the Wikipedia, though.
Well, my mom used to sing.
And we had music in the family.
So that's how I started.
I don't even remember
when I started singing.
I started in classical music.
I practiced since childhood
and I've been practicing.
But Bollywood is
a different thing.
I started in 2005.
I tried my luck in Bombay,
which is like, typically
Bollywood in India.
And it clicked.
And that's how I
went and moved on.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: OK, cool.
I know you actually competed
in several reality shows.
One was "Fame Gurukul" and one
was "10 Ke 10 Ke Le Gaye Dil".
ARIJIT SINGH: Yeah, that's the
only reality shows I've done.
In 2005, I came to
Mumbai and I did that.
And then, I started
meeting people in Mumbai
and tried singing
a lot of scratches.
I tried singing different tunes.
And that's how it is.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: And how did that
reality show affect your music?
ARIJIT SINGH: It affects.
It affects.
What happens is because
you're from a place where
there's no industry,
and you come to Mumbai
and that's basically the
central of the music industry.
And then that show
helps you to get
acquainted with the
musicians, the music
directors, and the
important people,
the VIPs in the industry.
So that's how you move on.
And you can think of the new
things, then you can plan.
So of course, any reality
show or any performance based
show that you're in, that
effects totally in your career.
So that's how we did it.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Definitely.
I watched the European
"Gurukul" show.
It's actually
really, really good.
So any-- so let's
start with this.
Who are your
biggest inspiration?
ARIJIT SINGH: In what?
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Singing,
getting into classical music.
Anything.
ARIJIT SINGH: OK.
I've done classical music a lot.
My inspiration was always my
teacher who used to teach me.
And Salam and Ali Khan
who started [INAUDIBLE]
concept, all these minstrels
of classical music and my mom.
I had several teachers
in Mumbai as well.
So these are my inspirations.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: OK.
Cool.
Let's say if you
had a chance to work
with any legendary singer,
Kishore Kumar or any of those,
who would you choose?
ARIJIT SINGH: Do you
have a time machine?
KUNAL AGGARWAL: We
might build one.
ARIJIT SINGH: Well,
Kishore Kumar is a legend.
He's been my favorite.
So of course, who wouldn't?
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Nice.
Nice.
OK.
Let's not talk about your songs.
First, let's talk about--
ARIJIT SINGH: Thank you.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: --other songs.
Who is your favorite
singer right now?
ARIJIT SINGH: There are many.
There are many.
I love-- in this lot?
Like, my generation?
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Yeah.
ARIJIT SINGH: I
like all of them.
I like Papon.
I like Beni.
I like Shalmali.
A lot of singers that
they're doing an amazing job.
And indeed if you see
in the '70s to 2000,
I have a list of
musicians that I like,
which are mostly
music composers.
R.D. Burman, S.D. Burman,
and then Nadeem-Shravan,
A.R. Rahman.
All these guys,
they are fantastic.
Spectacular music
they have been doing.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: OK.
Yeah, that's great.
How about any
international singers
do you want to get in
touch with or perform with?
ARIJIT SINGH: Well, I
don't know about getting
in touch with them.
But I have like,
John Mayer, I like.
I like Jason Miraz.
I like M.J, Michael Jackson.
That's been there forever.
And then, I like Elton John.
I like so many artists.
I can't really remember now.
It's lined up.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: OK.
Nice.
So you've done a lot
about Bollywood music.
I know you do a lot
of Bengali music.
That's where you're from.
So how different is it
singing for Bollywood
and then the place where you
live and other regional cities.
ARIJIT SINGH: Well, I started
singing in Bollywood first,
because I didn't try in Bengal.
I started singing Bengali songs,
original songs after I got
a chance to sing in Bollywood.
It's not different.
It's just a language.
Music is-- it remains the same.
The technicalities
are the thing that you
need to concentrate on, because
the industry has other aspects
as well in terms of if you see
production value of the music,
if you want to understand
the music production of it,
these things vary.
But the basic tune and the
lyrics, all that process
of making music are the same.
It doesn't make a difference.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: So
Roshni, so you have
such a versatile singer, right?
You have so many
languages you can sing in,
How do you prepare for a
concert with such magnitude,
really, with such talent?
How do you know you're giving
the best of Arijit Singh
to the audience?
ROSHNI SUCHDE: See
firstly, I think
the way his songs are popular,
I get calls from people telling
me, asking me, will he
be singing original songs
other than Hindi?
I said, if I do that,
we are limited people
of regional listeners, right?
So I have to make sure that
one thing that he's sings,
like Hindi, which
everybody is going to love,
eventually the people
who even speaks
Bengali understands Hindi more.
So they'll be like, Yeah.
Let's do that.
Let's keep Hindi.
So I think he does
justice to them.
He makes sure, I think, he sings
at least one line or something,
at least tailor to do.
Just to as, that, OK, I'll
make sure and I'll sing it.
So I think it's
all on the artist
that if you have
somebody like him,
you can easily pull
it off pretty well.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: That's great.
So Bollywood-- going
back to Bollywood--
they make about 150 movies--
ARIJIT SINGH: Films a year.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: I
mean, it's outstanding
how many movies they make.
ARIJIT SINGH: They
shouldn't, though.
They should make good movies.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: They
should make good movies.
So you probably
have a lot of calls
to rehearse a lot of songs.
And you might be put
in a situation where
you have to rehearse
a song very quickly
or rehearse multiple songs.
ARIJIT SINGH: It's
always like that.
The scene is like, I need
it yesterday every time.
So you have pressure.
And my manager
keeps troubling me.
And he keeps because there
are too many songs happening.
And it's really,
really difficult
to sing every other song for me.
So I need to keep a balance
also, so I plan it that way.
I skip a lot of songs.
Which ones I like, I sing.
Which ones I don't like,
I try to ignore politely.
So that's how I've
been managing.
I don't know in the future
how I'm going t o manage,
but that's the way it is.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Right.
Right.
No, that's good.
I mean, I've heard your songs,
and it's beautifully composed.
ARIJIT SINGH: Yeah.
I try to do good work to
my satifaction for what
I can bear.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: No.
But like your
songs, "Tum Hi Ho".
I mean, what a wide--
ARIJIT SINGH: That's
a brilliant song.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: --wide range.
Of course.
So it's amazing how you
handle the pressure.
So Is there any
song you would try
to do or try to sing differently
if you had a second chance?
ARIJIT SINGH: Every song.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Why is that?
ARIJIT SINGH: See it's
the, it's the mood of it.
It's not like a
mathematical calculation
that this song has
to sung this way.
It's basically your
interpretation every time.
You know, what you feel
and how are you today?
That how you sing it.
It's an expression.
So if you're were to
sing one song again,
it's going to be--
you can't make it
the same way, because
it's not a recording.
It's Inside you.
You sing one song every time,
it's going to be different.
That's music.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Actually,
I wanted to segue.
If you guys have audience
questions, we have two mics.
Two microphones, so
feel free to come up.
ARIJIT SINGH: Basically,
he's out of questions.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: So we at
Google, a lot of our employees
are in the tech-- this
is a tech company,
right-- and Google touches a
lot of different industries
in the world, especially
music and singing.
So how do you see technology and
Google products, like YouTube,
affect the music industry,
how you sing songs,
how has Indian music evolved?
ARIJIT SINGH: Well,
music has evolved a lot.
But I was checking this
to 365 video of Google,
and I was thinking why
aren't they making something
with the sound.
They're making so many
things with the video,
because of course,
sound has improved
a lot in all these years.
And because of the
technology, the music
has evolved a lot
in terms of sound,
in terms of melody, everything.
And the quality of it.
So of course, technology
is an important thing
in every aspect.
But Google should do
something sound-wise, I think.
It will help a lot of
people to bring out
more of this
criteria, more-- what
do you call it-- more regions,
more opportunities in music,
because music has no limits.
And technology
also has no limits.
If it bonds together, it
can do miraculous things.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: So one of the
things today in modern society
are singers use a
lot of Auto-tuners.
ARIJIT SINGH: See, Auto-tuners,
Auto-tune is just one way.
You have so many ways which can
completely modulate your voice
and transform any of the songs.
What Auto-tune does is
it just perfects a pitch.
That's the only thing it can do.
But it's not-- I don't
know why it's so hyped.
That's not much.
Actually, what we do
when a singer is singing
and he's singing very nice,
but there are glitches
and a little bit of
imperfection in the pitch,
we put Auto-tune on it.
That's great.
If you put Auto-tune
it handles a lot
of imperfection in the song.
It makes more automated.
That's nice, and of course,
any invention, either you
can make it perfect
or you can destroy it.
You do whatever you can.
Auto tune also has that aspect
that people are-- really
a lot of good singers
are really, really
angry at Auto-tune because
a lot of bad singers
are singing a lot of songs.
But I think that depends
on how you're using it.
Yeah, but it's not--
like, Salman Khan sang
and Akshay Humar sang.
It was good though.
I love it.
Sounds good.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: You have
an audience question.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
about Honey Singh's music?
ARIJIT SINGH: Honey Singh?
I love him.
AUDIENCE: What are some of
your favorite songs by him?
ARIJIT SINGH: Well, I
like-- all the songs there--
I like, what song is that?
That single that came out that's
a long nine minute single.
Which song was that?
He shot it in the US?
What song is that?
"Thousand Miles."
AUDIENCE: Yeah, "Thousand
Miles" is one of the songs.
It's their album.
"Desi Kalakaar".
ARIJIT SINGH: "Desi
Kalakaar", yes.
Exactly.
"Desi Kalakaar".
I love that song.
AUDIENCE: Interesting.
ARIJIT SINGH: Yeah, thank you.
Cool.
Honey's brilliant.
He's one of a kind.
No.
It's not.
I know Honey from before.
He's a music producer, and
he used to come to Pritam,
checking in with the studio.
He's been singing now, and
I know him from before.
So I know him very well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
So firstly, I've been following
you since "Fame Gurukul",
and still remember you
sang "Aashiq Banaya Aapne,"
and it was brilliant.
And I felt then that you
would have to be in Bollywood,
but we waited a little while.
But I was glad to see
that you made it big.
ARIJIT SINGH: What a wait, huh?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for sure.
Secondly, I went to
your concert last year.
Brilliant, so anyone who's
thinking about it, go.
It's just amazing.
The one thing I did
feel last year was you
sang other people's songs, too.
Your songs are way better,
so sing your songs.
I just had a baby
two months ago,
so I will not be
there this time.
ARIJIT SINGH: Congratulations.
AUDIENCE: But I will be there
next year if you come again.
ARIJIT SINGH: Yes, of course.
AUDIENCE: So I want to ask
you, what is your hardest
song that you sang,
because I know
you have such a range
of [INAUDIBLE], which
is super classical.
And now, you have done "Kabira".
You just have this
amazing range.
I think after Sonu Nigum
you are the first guy who
has such a range.
So what is the hardest song,
number one and secondly,
what's your favorite song?
And I have to go back because
my 3-year-old wants to sit.
ARIJIT SINGH: Please.
Please.
Hardest song.
OK.
Maybe the simplest song is
the hardest song to sing,
because you need to
express it properly.
So any song which
is the simplest
is going to be hardest.
And my favorite song
is definitely not mine.
Sorry to disappoint you,
but my favorite song
would be-- there are a lot of
songs, but I can remember now
is [INAUDIBLE] from Jagit Singh.
Yep.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Is
there another one?
AUDIENCE: Hi Arijit.
Thanks for coming to Google.
So just like the
lady just said, we've
all been following you
since "Fame Gurukul".
I know my entire
family voted for you
and when you didn't
win, we were very upset.
But I'm glad that you're here.
My question to you is a lot
of us found out about you
or rather, we started
hearing more about you
after "Tum Hi Ho", the
song from 2012 I guess.
And since then there's
been hits after hits,
and we all just listen to you
every day most of the time.
But I wanted to ask you,
when was that moment when
you realized you've arrived?
Like, you've been doing this
for probably these 10 years,
but was there a time
during this journey
when you realized,
OK, I've arrived now?
Or has that moment
still not come,
which means we are
still probably going
to get a lot from you?
ARIJIT SINGH: OK.
Nice question.
Well, it's been always like--
see, I've been an athlete.
I realize I don't
look like that.
It's like, if you
put a goal, you
put an ambition, like if it's
100 meters and then 200 meters,
so you arrive every day,
but you never arrive.
It's like that.
So I have goals in my
life, and I had goals
not like I had to
reach something.
But I have goals like
I need to sing this.
I need to sing that.
I need to sing all
the other aspects.
So these were my goals.
It's like a sport.
So you arrive once
you sing that,
and once you sing this,
and a lot of other things
that you can think of.
So after that, the point comes
when you think of something.
You imagine a genre.
You imagine something
which you have never seen,
and then you look for it.
That's also a journey.
So I think that
journey has started.
So it's going to be
this way until the end.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ARIJIT SINGH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Munji.
I have a quick question.
So before you were doing music
for yourselves as opposed
to now you're doing
it professionally,
how has it changed for you?
How do you think
about it differently?
Or has it not?
ARIJIT SINGH: It's
exhausting, because when
you do music for yourself, you
don't have any responsibility.
You don't have to think
of any boundaries.
Like, you have perform today or
you have to do this and that.
You don't think, you just
sing and you do your work.
The moment professionalism
comes you have responsibilities.
So you need to think of
how you perfect your thing
and you work harder and harder.
And you reach a point when you
start to feel scared about it,
because people are going
to expect a lot from you.
So all those pressures come.
That's the only difference.
AUDIENCE: Music-wise, you
feel anything different
that you could have
done differently
or if you had a chance you
would have done differently.
ARIJIT SINGH: I told you
every song every time,
maybe, because it's a
never ending process.
You can't really
calculate music.
So I always think that
whatever I've done let's
just forget it and move
on to the next thing.
That's the only way to go.
Otherwise, I'll be frustrated.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: What we want
to know as Google employees,
a lot of people have a passion
for music and performing art.
What advice do you have for
people in the technology sector
to follow what you do.
ARIJIT SINGH: I'm wrong person.
Technology.
OK, I need to think.
Maybe if it's much more
creativity, whatever you do,
whatever you discover, it's
always creative technique.
Technology is filtrated
into any choice.
But I think whoever wants
to do something technology,
I think they should.
I think they should find a way
to their imagination inside.
That's the only way to go.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Thank you.
ARIJIT SINGH: Thank you.
ROSHNI SUCHDE: I think over
there somebody is waiting.
AUDIENCE: If I may have one
last question, Love "Tum Hi Ho".
Love the unplugged version
even better in my opinion,
just because the
harmonic was great.
When you're making music for
the movies, do you visualize?
Do they give you
a clue as to what
you should be aiming towards or
do you sort of make something
and then they work
with it eventually?
Or how does that
entire process work?
ARIJIT SINGH: Well, it depends.
If you're scoring to a music,
like if you have a film
and you have to score for it,
then of course you have scenes.
And you have proper
brief of the emotions
and how it's going to go.
So that's easier, because you
have everything in front of you
and you can actually
sit with the director
and understand what's
the motive of the scene.
And then you score
it, score the melody.
And there is another
way of doing it.
It is you don't have a film.
You don't have a video of such.
You just have a script.
So you have to visualize it.
You're the director this time.
You have anything.
You can choreograph.
You become the director.
You become the cinematographer,
the light engineer,
and whatever you want to be.
You be that and you
imagine and score.
And later on if
the music is ready,
they'll do whatever after.
AUDIENCE: Are you
usually satisfied
with how everything works out?
ARIJIT SINGH: You're
never satisfied, bro.
Trust me.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
ARIJIT SINGH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks again for
coming to Google.
So you've been know to be
a little shy as compared
to other-- I don't know.
I was doing research on you and
that's my initial [INAUDIBLE].
So actually in my
research, I found out,
I read this article
in "Forbes" which
said you go to your
studio at midnight
to stay away from fans or
photographers or media.
And then I read
another article where
you said that the
"Forbes" article was fake.
So I want to hear from you.
Which one?
Did it happen, not happen?
On what's your take on general--
ARIJIT SINGH: "Forbes"
was a fake for sure.
AUDIENCE: OK.
They did a really good job.
ARIJIT SINGH: Convincing you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So what's your take
on the media in India
and the idolization
of superstars?
How has your life changed
now as compared to--
ARIJIT SINGH: I think we
have a huge population.
That's the problem.
Everyone is becoming
a part of the media,
and they are not studying media.
And they have a camera and
they know how to talk bullshit
and then they blab about it.
So that's when
the problem comes.
Otherwise, serious media people,
they are really, really genuine
and they want to do best.
With Bollywood, with the
whole music scenario,
all different scenarios, they've
been like page three every day.
So you can't really
go with the media
at all, because
they talk anything.
It's just random stuff they do.
So I think it's better
that if you follow them
on Twitter, if you
follow them on Facebook
or whatever social
media they're in,
that's the best thing to do.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Arijit.
Thanks for coming.
As it's been mentioned,
you're a wonderful singer.
You play the piano.
You play the guitar.
I'm a particular fan
of your MTV Unplugged.
ARIJIT SINGH: I don't play
it like a pro but I play it.
AUDIENCE: So I play
the guitar as well,
and I appreciate how
prominent the guitar often
is in a lot of your songs.
So I was just wondering is
there a particular instrument
that you have found to be most
effective in helping you convey
your emotion or
thoughts in a song,
or is there another instrument
that you hope to learn and pick
up along the way that you'd like
to see in some of your newer
singles?
ARIJIT SINGH: Well, I
think, I love the piano.
I think it's the most melodic
and purposed combination
of an instrument which is made.
But that's still unfair
to a lot of instruments
because I don't know them.
I would like to the learn-- it's
a very difficult instrument--
but I would like to
learn Cello, because it's
a very scientific instrument.
When I tried it,
it's I think not
my nature, not my lot
and not my cup of coffee.
It's very difficult. It's very,
very difficult. It's fretless.
It's heavy.
It's like your grandfather.
It's really difficult. I
think I would call off.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: So I
have a question for you.
What is life after music?
Are you into filming
or directing?
ARIJIT SINGH: OK.
I filmed something where
I thought I would--
It's like an
experiment that I've
done with 5D and the 1DC
camera lights and lenses.
I've started shooting
things, and I've
made something
which came out nice.
And I kind of like it.
It's OK.
It's not like film, but
it's a feature length film
that I've done.
I'm still working on it.
I'm still working on
the BGM and 5.1 mix.
Most probably it will
be ready by this year.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: Very good.
ARIJIT SINGH: OK, which one?
Sir.
AUDIENCE: OK, basically my
question is not from me.
It's from my son, [INAUDIBLE].
He's your big fan, and
he is entering puberty.
And he's asked me to
ask for your advice
as to how he should do the
vocal training during puberty.
I can't help it.
He asked me to ask.
ARIJIT SINGH: Just tell
him to sing at the time.
It's going to be fine.
AUDIENCE: Any particular like,
you had your classical training
going on.
So any particular
thing from that side.
ARIJIT SINGH: Well,
I think I don't
have a one liner for this.
I think he should be
happy and just let it go.
It's OK.
He'll be fine.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'll tell him.
Thank you.
ARIJIT SINGH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Well, first of all
I want to congratulate you.
You're one of those
singers who really
knows how to carry himself
with great style and class.
And you make all of
us very, very proud.
One thing I will say that
your song like "Tum Hi Ho"
is literally the anthem.
And I think in the
form of romance,
it's will carry that chart
for the rest of the world.
This show that you're
presenting in the US today,
you've chosen very
selective cities
and it's very rare that we
see an Indian show coming
with a symphony orchestra.
And you've been very selective
in doing just a few shows,
but you want to put your full
effort on this particular tour.
Can you tell us
the grand symphony
that's performing
with you and how
this show is going
to be different
that only about seven cities
are going to be experiencing?
ARIJIT SINGH: Yeah, the symphony
thing is a little new for me
as well.
It's first of all,
the Indian music
has nothing to do with
symphony because symphony
is purely Western classical.
But we're blending it.
People have been doing it in
[INAUDIBLE] from '70s and '60s
actually.
We had the Bombay Symphony
Orchestra in the past.
But we don't have much
musicians in India
where they are not keen on.
Basically, it's a propaganda.
So we don't have
good musicians who
can play horn section and string
section, wood wind section.
We don't have a good
instruments as well.
So that was something
which we were lacking.
And we tried to do a blend
of an alternating music
and symphonic music together so
that it doesn't get monotonous.
And at the same time, you have
a classic flavor to your songs.
I think [INAUDIBLE]
is the only guy who's
been really working hard at
this for a very, very long time.
And he has worked on it so hard
that I think after five years
we'll get musicians who can play
symphonic structure in India as
well.
And certainly, he's doing it.
So I think music will rise.
For now, what our thing is,
if we want to do symphonic
we have to hire
people from outside.
So I did Dubai gig
with symphony so we
have to book a symphony
orchestra from London.
And then, we did London
and then we didn't Mumbai.
But in Mumbai we only
had [INAUDIBLE] strings
and a couple of wood winds.
So we had to compromise.
This time, it's the
hub of symphony.
Anyway, the US is like
the hub of, the central
of symphony orchestras.
We had good musicians
coming up, and we
gathered all the musicians.
And it's like a
richness to your music.
It gives a different
flavor to it.
It has a different texture.
It's very cinematic.
And if you can imagine a film
with a [INAUDIBLE] orchestra
playing, a lot of musicians
playing, and giving you
a grandeur of it.
So symphony would be sounding
like that in the show.
But at the same
time, because as I
funk it up, because we have
two guitarist, one bassist, one
drummer, so we have an
alternative metal rock
kind of a band.
That blending with
the symphony orchestra
is giving a different
flavor unlike it.
So that's how we're doing it.
And I'm really, really
not sure about how
it's going to sound,
because most of the time
I'm lost with the
symphony thing.
It's so big and
it's so difficult
to handle all the musicians
and the technicals.
You know, it was really, really
difficult for me on those days.
But I'm hoping for the best.
I have a lot of shows.
I think the first two shows
and after that I'll be informed
and I can see everything
on stage, I guess.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
will say one thing.
I'm the promoter who's
doing the show in Houston.
People are flying in
from different states,
in different cities, just
to be a part of that show.
You've always been
a man of few words,
but the magnitude and the
quality that you always
focus on is the reason why
we are all here at the Google
studio.
And I really want to
congratulate you for that.
ARIJIT SINGH: Thank
you very much.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: I have
a question for you.
So for the people who
want to learn singing,
would you ever consider
opening a school
to teach your style,
your technique,
teach music to other people?
ARIJIT SINGH: You
mean me teaching?
Yes.
Not now, because
I'm still learning.
I think I would be ready
by another 20 years.
Like just ready to teach
a couple of people,
not everyone, because teaching
is a different art altogether.
So I'm learning to do it,
because it's very, very
important to teach music
because it's not only
to understand that
if you know music
it's not necessarily you have to
sing in Hollywood or Bollywood
or any other platform.
Singing is an art and you
can sing for yourself.
Making it a career is
a different option.
So we need to understand
any performing art is not
commercial always.
So that's the thing I think
I'm still struggling on it.
I am still looking
for an answer where
I can understand myself of how
am I going to convince people.
So that's going to take time,
and I have a plan for a school
later on.
That's going to be kick ass.
KUNAL AGGARWAL: All right.
Cool.
So this concludes
our talk for today.
But we would like to give
a huge round of applause
to Mr. Arijit Singh Thank
you so much for coming here.
ARIJIT SINGH: It
was my pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]